what we are going to do in this video is
discuss the United States Senate we're
gonna focus not only on areas where the
Senate has special influence where the
House of Representatives does not but
we'll also focus on how the Senate
actually conducts business and as we'll
see the processes and the rules that the
Senate uses makes it more difficult for
a simple majority to do what they want
so in terms of special influence only
the Senate not the House of
Representatives is involved in ratifying
treaties so the executive the president
they can negotiate a treaty but it does
not become effective binding from a
United States point of view until it is
ratified by the United States Senate and
it has to be ratified by a two-thirds
supermajority and this is one of the
reasons why it is viewed that the Senate
has more influence on Foreign Relations
than the House of Representatives the
other area that the Senate is involved
is in confirming appointments these
could be appointments to the president's
cabinet these can also be judiciary
appointments it could be to lower
federal courts or to the United States
Supreme Court the House of
Representatives once again is not
involved but to appreciate just how
things go through the Senate whether
we're talking about appointments or even
if we're talking about general
legislation let's remind ourselves the
overall process so let's just say that
this is a piece of legislation right
over here it could have been drafted by
a staffer for a senator maybe with help
from some constituents or from some
special interest groups maybe some
lobbyists and it will be introduced to
an appropriate committee by a senator or
by a group of senators for example if
this legislation is about the Armed
Services it would go to the Armed
Services Committee now the committee
could decide to have some hearings
around the legislation maybe they bring
in the Secretary of Defense maybe they
bring in some military leaders and ask
them questions about their views about
whether the legislation is a good idea
or not or they just want general context
then they might also have some debate
and then they might decide to vote on
that legislation and if
vote passes if they get a majority in
that committee then it will go to the
Senate floor now before we even talk
about what happens on the floor of the
Senate because that's where things get
really interesting it's important to
point out that even within committee the
leadership has a lot of influence and
the leadership is generally controlled
by the majority party because the
leadership might decide that hey you
know what they're not interested in this
bill so instead of going through this
process here they might just decide to
table the bill which kind of just puts
it into a limbo well let's talk about
the reality where it does get voted on
it does get a majority and it goes to
the Senate floor now what's going to
happen next in the Senate floor is a
debate over that bill and I'm writing
debate in caps because the Senate is
famous for its debates and the whole
idea of ending a debate so that you can
vote is critical inside of the Senate
once you get to the vote if we're
talking about a general piece of
legislation if we're talking about an
appointment then you just need a simple
majority so you just need 51 votes to
pass now some of you might be saying
wait hold on a second I've always heard
that it in the Senate in order to do
anything you need a supermajority you
might have heard the 60 vote number the
reason why you hear that is because many
times the folks who do not want to have
a vote especially if they think that the
vote is going to go against them that
one senator or could be a group of
senators that say hey I want to keep
debating on it and this protracted
debate is known as a filibuster which is
a very strange word it was originally in
reference to pirates but it came to mean
folks who are trying to hold up the
legislation process and it's become a
mechanism by which the folks who don't
want the vote who might be against the
bill who might be in the minority they
might not have enough votes to defeat
the bill might still try to hold things
up now the reason why you've heard about
60 votes is because generally speaking
that is how you stop a filibuster if you
want to stop a filibuster you need to do
something call cloture or another way of
thinking about its closure of the debate
so that you can get to a vote and the
reason why you hear 60 votes is for
general legislation you need 60 votes in
order to have cloture so even though
only need 51 votes for the legislation
to pass once you vote on it to even get
to that point you need 60 votes and this
is why you hear that for legislation to
actually get through the Senate you need
60 votes now there is an exception to
this and that exception is around
appointments prior to 2013 in order to
have cloture for an appointment you also
needed 60 votes but in 2013 it was
decided that for non Supreme Court
appointments you only needed 51 votes
for cloture and then in 2017 this was
extended also to Supreme Court
appointments and so now for appointments
you only need 51 votes for cloture to
end a filibuster and so and of course
you only need 51 votes for the
confirmation so functionally you just
need a simple majority now in the Senate
for confirmations but legislation you
need 60 votes and of course for things
like treaties you need a two-thirds
supermajority to convict someone in an
impeachment and say the president you
need a two-thirds supermajority and like
the house if we are talking about
overriding a presidential veto or
amending the Constitution you need a
two-thirds majority now what I've just
talked about it isn't extensive it isn't
exhaustive of all of the processes in
the Senate but hopefully it gives you
appreciation of one areas where the
Senate has special influence and also
how the rules and processes of the
Senate can be leveraged by either
majority parties or minority parties in
order to get things done and how in the
Senate it is harder for a simple
majority to do whatever they want